I was on our reddit discussion forum
this morning which is a great place to
consort with other david pakman show
viewers and listeners you can access our
reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT here's some
interesting discussions from the reddit
discussion forum starting with someone
saying what was the run-up to the Iraq
war like this is interesting because
we've got a lot of younger viewers now
viewers now who don't remember what the
propaganda situation was in the run-up
to the Iraq war and they're sort of
wondering are we seeing a similar
propagandistic approach with regard to
North Korea or Iran from the Trump
administration so a nice discussion
about what was the run-up to the Iraq
war like on our reddit discussion forum
also on reddit this morning does the
YouTube funding crisis paired with the
Patrick bird hater Ford scandal mean
that this co-host job security is in
question don't do it we like Pat we need
Pat and we all make mistakes some of us
more often than others Pat's job is not
in danger I've made that clear to Pat
and you know we are on our way to
replacing the lost revenue and if that
continues we will be able to continue
the david pakman show unfettered and i
think that people will be pleased to
hear that i'm sure when you asked me to
join the team though that you didn't
realize that i had so many scandals in
my past that like i use a keurig let my
cat go outside and kill migratory birds
yeah yeah five skandhas a couple classes
a lot continuing with interesting posts
from reddit possible speakeasy
dictionary for the david pakman show so
the idea here is that because of the
possible sort of system that youtube
might be implementing in the wake of the
ad boycott to figure out what words were
using and blocking ads as a result
people are suggesting we use a sort of
alternative dictionary so instead of
saying drone strike we talk about a red
shell or instead of talking about
terrorism we use the term babysitting or
instead of you know religion we use the
term romani ology or whatever the thing
is this alone won't solve the problem
because our entire channel has been
blacklisted but it's interesting talking
in a sort of
it's also hard to attract new viewers
and we get in on what these words mean
yeah people would say there's something
clearly wrong with David Pakman what on
earth is this guy talking about but an
interesting idea nonetheless also from
our ready discussion forum the YouTube
ad self-censorship reminds me of the
1993 film demolition man right the idea
where we would start to self-censor
because we know that certain topics
won't be monetized on YouTube the
reality is nothing is monetized on
youtube so we might as well talk about
whatever the hell we want to talk about
and that's why we open the show by
talking about Syria and Russia to that's
exactly right and lastly from the reddit
discussion forum I really admire and
respect David's attitude about the whole
YouTube ad thing and a discussion going
about that so listen in the same way
that we are not self-censoring on the
show all topics as long as you're not
trolling or insulting people or
attacking individuals on the forum all
topics are open for discussion at david
pakman.com slash reddit and of course
you can help us with the YouTube ad
boycott we are down to 34 cents a day in
YouTube ad revenue even though we have
about 500,000 views a day you can go to
patreon.com/scishow vad pakman show to
contribute